I talked a little bit last time about
what we were going to cover,
but I didn't get quite through.
So I'm going to finish that.
For those of you who weren't here last
time,
you can watch the lecture because it's
online.
So,
um,
we,
we stopped at the depths.
Psychologists.
Really those are the psychoanalysts and
psychoanalysts are people who are
concerned with,
okay,
well for a psychoanalyst,
roughly speaking,
you're a collection of loosely
integrated spirits.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Or sub personalities.
You're not a unity and no sub
personalities have their basis in while
in all sorts of things.
They might have their basis in past,
especially traumatic experience or in
patterns of socialization that
characterized your family.
But they might also have their basis in
fundamental biological motivational
systems.
So for example,
a psychoanalyst would conceptualize it,
anger or,
or perhaps sexual attraction as a sub
personality.
And the reason for that is that,
well,
you know what it's like when you get
angry,
you get angry at someone you love and
you know,
first of all,
you,
you know,
it's some level you're wishing harm.
Now that might only be that you want to
win the argument and you want them to be
nicely crushed while you do it.
But so,
so there's a desire that comes along
with the anger,
but,
but there's a lot of other things that
happen to,
so for example,
if someone's annoying you,
even if you love them,
the profitability that at that moment
you're going to be able to easily access
all the memories you have about how
annoying they are and have difficult
time accessing the memories about how
wonderful they mean he was quite high.
You know,
and you know that because sometimes you
get angry with someone who had an
argument with them and you sort of clue
in later you'll snap out of you're more
or less possessed state and you think,
yeah,
well,
you know,
I really wasn't taking the context into
mind and I was kind of harsh,
so,
well,
so and so.
Then you think,
well who's in control?
And that's the question the
psychoanalysts are really interested in.
And their answer is it's not generally
you.
And so it's very terrifying reading in
some sense because you know,
people like to think of themselves as
masters of their own house so to speak.
And it's just,
it's only vaguely true.
And you know people,
you know that too,
cause you make
maybe new years eve,
uh,
what do you call those resolutions?
How you're going to be a better person.
I think one of the most common ones is,
man,
you're going to hit the gym three times
a week.
It's like,
no,
you're not actually.
And so very few people do.
And that's partly because,
well,
it's hard and so you don't want to do
hard things and what they aren't.
The reason for that is because they're
hard.
So it doesn't take much explanation.
But it's also because you can't just
tell yourself what to do.
And that's annoying too because life
would be a lot easier if you could just
say,
okay,
well you don't sit down study for two
hours,
don't watch cats on youtube or whatever
it is that you're watching.
And No,
no,
that isn't what happens.
You sit there and you study for a while
and then you know,
you're thinking about cats and next
thing you know you're watching haunted
mansion's in London or some damn thing,
you know,
so,
and it's a scary idea in some sense
because if you think,
well,
if you're not really master of your own
house,
you know,
if you don't have yourself under full
voluntary control and you certainly
don't,
then what does,
and you know,
Freud is interesting in that regard
because he really talked about the
motive,
power of fundamental motivational
systems mostly for Freud it was
aggression in sexuality,
you know,
and those are,
those are big motivators.
Let's make no mistake about it.
And so he thought of you as,
as,
uh,
that the conscious part of your
personality may be as the,
it's like the captain of a ship with a
very unruly crew.
It's a nice metaphor because of course
the ships on the ocean and the ocean can
be very stormy.
And so you can only sort of plot your
course and you have to work with what's
thrown at you.
And then the unruly crew is,
well it's all your drives.
It drives is the wrong way of thinking
about it.
That I liked the psychoanalytic notion
of subpersonality because a
subpersonality has a viewpoint,
there's things it wants and it plants.
So it's,
it's,
it's an,
it's a living entity.
It's not some dead cognitive system.
So Freud was interested in some sense
more about,
I would say the biological underpinnings
of the subpersonalities,
you know,
because he was,
he was,
he was quite biologically oriented and
he realized that sexuality and
aggression,
we're very fundamental sub personalities
and then there's young and young is much
more terrifying than Freud,
which is really saying a lot because
Freud's quite terrified.
But Young,
he,
he's just terrified beyond belief.
And you know,
for you the sub personalities that make
you up are thousands and thousands of
years old.
They're cultural constructions that are
thousands and thousands of years old and
they have you in their grip.
So for union,
for example,
one of the things he said,
and I don't remember where it was,
I love this phrase,
it's so true.
And you can think about this for like
five years and,
and you can still think about it after
that.
One of the things young said was that
people don't have ideas,
ideas have people.
And that's really something to think
about because you know,
just think about your own situation.
So no doubt you have political views and
you think I have political views.
It's like,
well no you don't because you share them
with a lot of other people.
So there are certainly not yours.
And not only that,
they've had a very lengthy historical
development far before you ever showed
up,
you know,
so they're rooted in rooted right at the
depths of your culture.
But then of course they'd been
elaborated by one philosopher or another
extensively over the last two or 300
years.
And there's this whole system of thought
and Poof,
it had habits.
Your brain,
and then you think,
well,
I've got political views.
It's like,
no,
the political views have you.
And that's a very salutary thought
because it's one of the ways to stop
yourself from being possessed because
people get possessed all the time by
ideas.
Right.
That's what happened in Nazi Germany.
That's what happened in the Soviet
Union.
It happens everywhere all the time.
And you might think,
well possessed is a little strong but,
but no,
it's not actually,
it's a very nice,
it's a metaphor obviously,
but it's the right kind of metaphor
because a body of ideas,
like political ideas,
there are living thing,
you know,
they're not,
they're not some dead dusty words on a
bookshelf somewhere.
They're an integral part of a dynamic
society and,
and the motive force,
those ideas have motivates you.
You're in their grip.
And so you can tell when you're talking
to someone who's completely possessed by
it,
by an idea system or in India logical
system,
cause they'll just bore you to death
unless you happen to believe exactly the
same thing.
So they will spout out a few of their
fundamental belief axioms and then you
can identify which system they're part
of and then they just speak in cliches
from that point onward.
And you can predict everything you're,
they're going to say if you know the
axioms of the system.
So it's very,
it's very non authentic speech.
And that would be a way that,
say someone like Rogers or,
or,
or Abraham Maslow who were humanists of
the 1960s might talk about it because
the person isn't speaking from the
depths of their own experience or from
even their embodied knowledge,
you know,
they're just mouthpieces for abstract
ideas.
And so it's very frightening to realize
the extent to which you can be the
mouthpiece for abstract ideas,
you know?
And it's actually one of the dangers of
becoming educated,
especially in a mass system like the
university system.
Because a lot of what happens to you
when you come to university is that
you're fed a set of
pre digested ideas.
I suppose that's one way of thinking
about it,
you know,
and it's very easy for you to think,
well,
it,
those are now your ideas.
They're not,
they're not lots of ideas that you have
to earn.
And if it's a great idea,
then you really have to earn it because
why should you just be able to come
along and like pluck up a great idea.
That's not how things work.
You have to earn things that are
valuable.
So anyways,
the depth psychologist man,
they're so good at that.
It's lovely to read them.
And the problem too is with a lot of the
people we're going to talk about,
it's very difficult to summarize their
work.
You know,
cause often the devil's in the details.
So you know,
you might look at someone like piaget is
a good example.
The constructivists that we talked about
briefly,
man,
the guy wrote dozens of books.
He can't just summarize those suckers.
It's not one coherent theory that you
can boil down to,
you know,
10 axioms and then you can read it while
you're flying from Toronto to Montreal
and Poof,
you're appears.
Yet even psychologists,
like it doesn't work like that.
The people who may,
who formulated these theories were
extremely intelligent and um,
and,
and there are often great writers.
And so a lot of the knowledge is
actually in the writing itself and not
in what you can extract out from the
just,
you know,
and most of the theorists,
Freud Young,
it's harder,
but freud,
Rogers,
people like that you can extract out the
gist of their theories and then you can,
uh,
what would you say?
You can,
you can stereotype it or you can correct
it.
Sure it.
And then you can point out how your
caricatures observed and then you can
feel like you're even smarter than
Freud.
You know,
you're not.
So it's not a good idea.
And so these people should also be
approached with respect cause man,
they have so much to tell you.
It's so useful.
Okay.
So we talked about the depth
psychologist,
we talked about the constructivists,
we didn't talk about the humanists,
the existentialists and the
phenomenologists and a mouthful of
words,
you know.
So let's put a little bit of foundation
under those.
So if you're a humanist,
to be a humanist means really to be a
creature of the enlightenment.
And a human is thought in some sense,
at least this is what the humanist
thing,
they think of it as post religious.
They think of a humanistic thought as
putting the value of the human being at
the center of the cosmos in some sense,
valuing the person as they are and then
also valuing the person that they could
be and and promoting the pathways of
development that would allow people to
become what they could be as creatures
that are valuable in their own right.
So a humanist for example,
would be very skeptical of claims.
So let's say standard Christian claims,
and I use that example because the realm
of ideas that these thinkers emerged out
of was almost always Judeo Christian.
And so,
you know,
they're,
the roots of their thinking are in those
systems and you can't understand their
thinking without understanding that.
And so part of humanism was a rebellion
against the idea that life on earth,
so to speak,
was of limited value because everything
of any importance was going to happen in
the afterlife after you die.
So it's like,
no,
it's here and now it's right now that
matters.
And you know,
life in the present is what's important
and you don't need some kind of
afterlife for some kind of belief in a
transcendent reality in order to find
value right here and now.
So you know,
fight,
there's a lot of good things about that
idea,
you know,
and,
and the whole idea that you can improve
yourself in some sense is that
humanistic idea.
And most of you,
I mean,
how many of you believe that you can
improve yourself?
So is there anybody who doesn't believe
that it's,
that's willing to admit it.
So usually people only don't believe
that if they're very depressed or
hopeless,
but it's,
it's not self evident,
you know,
I mean,
and,
and in many cultures you can think of
medieval culture,
for example,
in Europe where you know,
you were sort of stuck in your position.
There was no real idea of self
improvement.
You could try not to sin,
but you aren't going to get like
radically better in some way.
You were just who you are.
And that was that.
But not,
that's not the case for the no.
Existentialists there are kind of a
different kettle of fish.
So you know when Fred talks about
psychopathology,
because a lot of personality is about
pathology,
right?
How personal this can go wrong.
Freud kind of thinks of the normal
person roughly speaking as healthy in
their normality,
but perhaps transformed into a
pathological version of themselves by
some sort of past trauma.
And that might often be an abusive
childhood,
you know,
or,
or maybe a sexually abusive childhood
because you know,
Freud talked a lot about that and it
happens fairly frequently.
So for Freud,
all things considered,
if you weren't healthy,
there was a reason for it.
You know,
something terrible that happened to you
and you needed to come to terms with
that terrible thing.
However you might do that and put
yourself back together and then you
could wander along being a healthy
person.
But the existentialists,
that's not how they think at all.
They think that standard human being is
pathological.
And the reason they think that is
because they think that self conscious
existence,
so life,
the life of a creature that knows it's
bounded in time and space,
right?
Knows it's vulnerable to disease and
illness and death and the loss of things
that,
that they love.
And the disintegration of all things in
some sense is that's enough of a problem
to give you problems without having to
have been abused by it.
And so the existentialists view life
itself as a problem of sufficient
magnitude that it can destabilize you
mentally merely by being aware of it.
And so they also believe that often what
people do as a consequence of that is
flee from their own awareness,
you know?
So how do you deal with the fact that
life is suffering?
Well,
you don't think about it.
for an existentialist,
that's not a very good answer.
And I would also say generally speaking,
for clinical psychologists,
that's also not a very good answer
because the literature suggests pretty
damn strongly that the harder you run
from something you're afraid of,
the larger it becomes and the faster it
chases you.
So avoidance of avoidance is generally a
very bad strategy.
Now,
it's not always the case because
sometimes if you can't do anything about
something really,
you can,
well,
there's not a lot of sense spending a
lot of time planning and struggling
against it.
You know,
when sometimes people are in generally
genuinely hopeless situations,
but,
but often did not.
So I really liked the [inaudible] man.
I think they're,
well,
I,
all the people that we're going to talk
about there,
you're thinking is extraordinarily
valuable.
You know,
it helps situate you in your own life.
It helps clarify the nature of your
relationship to other people in the
world.
It helps you lay out what your future
could be if you were the creatures that
you could be really wonderful.
Phenomenologists there are tricky bunch.
Um,
fundamental phenomenologist was Martin
Heidegger,
who was also somewhat also somewhat
tangled up with the Nazis.
Um,
you know,
which was clearly not a good thing.
And you know,
people debate about whether or not you
can separate out his philosophy from
what tangled them up with the Nazis.
And I think you can,
you know.
So anyways,
heidegger,
heidegger learned to take a fresh look
at the nature of reality.
And so heidegger,
his idea was that we,
we made a fundamental philosophical era
way back when when we were Greek,
ancient Greek,
roughly speaking,
and that we started concentrating on the
wrong elements of he didn't read,
he doesn't recall it.
Reality calls it being so a
phenomenologist is someone who's
concerned with Ba and you,
you might think,
well what's the difference between being
in reality?
And the answer to that is it depends.
It depends on how you define being and
it depends on how you define reality.
So heidegger's observation was that for,
for,
for modern people,
roughly speaking,
reality is sort of a d animated material
objective.
Substrata it's,
it's dead in its essence,
roughly speaking.
And the things that are most real are
precisely those things.
You can think about that it's all
objective reality for all intents and
purposes.
But what,
what heidegger tried to point out is
that there's,
it's a choice in some sense because your
knowledge is finite because you're
fundamentally ignorant about all things.
You have to decide that certain things
are true and then act from that point.
And you know,
heidegger's point was,
there's a lot of things that you can
decide about at the very fundamental
level of,
of axiom.
And so one of the things you can decide
for example,
is whether or not the objective world is
what's more real or whether or not your
lived experience is what's more real.
Now you might think,
well what's the distinction there?
And I would say the distinction is
probably something like watching someone
in pain on a video and being in pain
yourself,
you know,
so is a good example of,
of an element of being,
because it's obviously,
it's obviously you experienced it within
your own.
It's hard to talk about this because he
uses different terminology.
Pain is an element of your big,
and it's,
it's not something,
it's,
the pain itself is not something that
you can even conceptualize in objective
terms.
Like you can measure it,
you know,
maybe your heart rate goes up when
you're in pain or something like that,
or your facial expressions change,
you know,
so you can index it.
But the indexes are not the phenomena
that's hence phenomenology.
Right?
And so the phenomenologists have built
up an entire system of thinking,
predicated on the initial axiom that the
best way to approach life is to assume
that being is the fundamental reality
rather than the,
as the fundamental level.
And then you might think,
well,
why do people farther with that sort of
thing?
And part of it is one of the cool,
this is an existentialist plate.
One of the consequences of developing
the objective theory of existence was
obviously all of the amazing technology
we have around us and you know,
great,
thank God for that.
Otherwise we'd be sitting outside
freezing.
But one of the consequences of that is
once people established or objective
reality and then defined it as
ultimately real terrible questions of
the meaning of life,
the ropes,
you know,
like if the world,
the universe is made out of nothing but
dead matter,
it's eternally existing.
We're nothing but a candle flash in the
wind.
The idea creeps into your mind that
perhaps all of the damn suffering isn't
worth it or,
or can put it another way,
you know,
does your life really have any,
any real meaning or is that just an
illusion?
Well,
heidegger would say the reason that you
have that problem is because you're
approaching the entire problem wrong.
Clearly things have meaning.
They just don't.
If you make the hypothesis that's what's
our objective is ultimately real and
everything else is merely a secondary
consequence of that.
So anyways,
it's complicated.
It takes a while to get your head around
it.
Um,
the humanists and the existentialists
and to some degree,
the phenomenologists,
they all came out of,
there isn't,
there was a variety of sources for their
thoughts.
And I would say one of them is the clash
between religion and science or between,
between value and objective truth.
They're trying to,
to rectify the division.
And Piaget himself was trying to do some
of that as well.
So it was young,
I guess.
Um,
and the other thing is a lot of the
existentialist and humanist work was
post World War II.
And so,
you know,
after World War Two happened with its
immense catastrophes of course people
who were thinking about human nature,
we're very interested in why such a
thing could happen and existentialism at
least as a psychological school arose in
part as a reaction to the horrors of
World War II.
It's a very serious,
it's a very serious branch of
psychology.
And it would mostly characterize
thinking in the 1950s before the hippies
came along and made everything sweetness
and light.
So,
which is more where Roger's in a maslow
outfit.
So,
so we're going to talk about them a fair
bit that the three different categories.
So it's a kind of a strange approach in
some sense that this class takes,
because I talked to you about some
psychologists in that,
in that period.
But the other,
the people I talked to you mostly about
aren't sec,
they're not technically psychologists.
Depends on what you mean by
psychologist.
After all,
I talk a lot about Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky and also a lot about a
Russian literary figure.
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn who wrote a book
called the Gulag archipelago,
which was one of the,
there's a few cataclysmic events that
brought the totalitarian system of the
Soviet Union to a halt.
And you can argue about what they were,
but one of them for sure with social
nuts as published publication of the
Gulag Archipelago,
which is a 2,700 word book,
2,700 page book.
Can I get that right?
That describes what it was like to be
there and how many people died.
And it's a,
it's a searing book.
He won a Nobel prize and he deserved it.
I mean,
soldier had some remarkable person.
He's like the Dostoyevsky of the 20th
century.
And that's really saying something.
And Dostoyevsky is another person I use
a lot in that section.
And both Dostoyevsky and nature regarded
themselves as psychologists
fundamentally.
And you know,
it's funny because when you think about
scientists,
you know,
usually think about people who are
conducting experiments,
right?
But then one of the things,
and you'll notice this,
if you think about it,
it's a lot of you have taken a fair
number of science courses or one of one
form or another.
And you know a lot of what you're taught
when you're taught how to do sides is
how to generate,
you know,
how to lay out that experiment property,
how to get the methodology right,
how to do the analysis property,
maybe how to structure the,
the,
the revealing of your findings in proper
scientific format.
You know,
and how to test a hypothesis.
But one of the things that you're never
really told about as well,
how the hell do you generate the
hypotheses to begin with?
Because you know,
really that's at least half of the
problem.
And it's probably a lot more than half
the problem.
And so part of being a scientist is the
ability to be a hypothesis generator,
not just a hypothesis test or maybe you
need to be both to be a true scientist,
but,
but maybe not.
Maybe you can just generate
extraordinary hypothesis.
And it's certainly the case that people
like dusty Sdn Nietzsche were
unbelievably good hypotheses generators.
And so,
you know,
they're thinking in many ways underlies
the entire development of thought,
that sort of thought that you guys are
going to encounter in university
anyways.
They're thinking underlies the entire
development of the edifice of,
I would say both scientific and
nonscientific thought across the entire
entire 20th century.
And so it's quite entertaining to,
to go down there and you know,
uh,
wander around the roots of these sorts
of things because you find out how
things are linked together and why
they're linked together and how they
developed and what that means.
And also what it means for you to have
those ideas and why you have them and
what role they play in your life.
So,
okay,
so after that,
that's pretty much in some sense you
might think that's where the clinical
and philosophical part of the course
ends.
Now I'm a clinical psychologist and most
of the people who are great personality
theorists were clinical psychologists.
And that explains to some degree why the
first part of the courses philosophical,
because the thing about clinical
psychologists and psychiatrists and
medical doctors for that matter is that
they're not exactly scientists.
They're more like engineers.
So what an engineer wants to do,
they might,
an engineer might use scientific
knowledge and you know,
good for them.
They should,
but really what they want to do is make
something change.
They want to build something,
they want to transform something.
They want to act on the world in,
in a beneficial,
generally in a beneficial way.
While the same thing as the case with
the health domains,
it's like someone comes to you with a
psychological problem.
What you want to do is you want to make
it better and better.
It's not a scientific category.
So to the degree that you're a
practical,
like you can say,
well,
it's scientific because worst means
abnormal.
It's like,
that's not right.
You can make that case,
but it's shallow because there's lots of
times when you don't consider normal
healthy,
you know,
you can send her exceptional,
healthy,
right or,
or maybe you consider exceptional,
desirable and desirable.
It might even be better than healthy,
right?
So you can't get out of the value domain
when you're trying to interact with
people and sort out their lives.
Because partly what you're,
what you're always asking is what's
wrong?
What's the matter?
Why are you dissatisfied?
Why are you suffering?
Why aren't you productive?
Why do you fight with everyone?
You know,
why can't you sleep at night?
Why do you wake up screaming,
you know,
why can't you pursue anything that's to
your own benefit?
Why do you hurt everyone that you know,
you know,
those are moral questions.
And then the next problem is,
okay,
well what are we going to do about it?
What do you want?
How would you like your life to look if
it could look the way you wanted it to?
And then how are we going to get from
where you are to that?
And those are all their engineering
questions in a sense,
but above all their ethical questions
because they deal with how to act.
So I'm not,
you know,
I don't want to just slide over that big
because that's generally what happens
because physicians and clinical
psychologists and psychiatrists,
even though their physicians,
they like to think that what they're
doing is science and that's not right.
It's informed by science.
But that's not the same thing.
It's particularly true with doctors
because they're not even trained to be
scientists.
So,
okay,
so that's that.
So then the next part of the course,
the last half,
it's,
it's pretty,
it concentrates on two elements of
personality theory,
more modern elements I would say,
although not more valuable necessarily
because of that.
Um,
partly very neurobiological because we
made a lot of strides in the last 5,000
years,
let's say in understanding the,
the,
the structure and the function of the
brain.
Like the things we don't know about the
brain,
man,
it's,
there are lots of things we don't
understand about the brain.
We have no idea,
for example,
what its relationship is to
consciousness,
except that more or less it seems
necessary.
You know,
so all,
even even that you can dispute to some
degree because they're great case
histories of people who were born with
hydrocephalus.
And so that means that your skull
basically fills with water.
And the most famous case of that was a
French guy who,
uh,
went for an Mri for God only knows what
reason.
It had nothing to do with,
with uh,
what was eventually discovered,
but he only had 5% of his cortical
tissue is whole brain.
His whole head was full of cerebral
spinal fluid and the brain was just a
little skin around the side that was
like a balloon.
And as far as they could tell,
there was nothing wrong with them.
It's like,
hmm,
well isn't that interesting?
What the Hell is all the risks that
brain for,
you know,
and then you get the other issue.
Like,
I don't know if you ever heard of,
uh,
can't remember her name.
I think it's peppered.
She had a famous parrot and African
gray.
You can look it up talking African gray
parrot and that damn parrot,
man,
that thing could talk like a four year
old kid.
Way better than any chimpanzee full
sentences.
It seemed to know what it was doing.
It's like it's a parrot,
right?
It's brain is this big.
So how is that even possible?
So,
okay,
so there's lots of things we don't know
about the brain really,
and he's unbelievably complicated.
So,
but we have learned a lot of things that
are interesting.
We kind of understand the existence and
the location of the fundamental reward
and pain and anxiety circuits.
That's a big deal.
Those are,
those are like discovering major
continents,
you know,
we understand to some degree how people
learn and under what conditions they
learn.
And we understand,
I would say to some degree what the
fundamental motivations and emotions are
now,
those are not scientific categories,
motivations and emotions,
their linguistic categories.
So what we're stuck with.
So,
but we,
we know a fair bit about their
underlying neuro biological basis.
And I want to take you through that in
some detail because for a bunch of
reasons,
partly because it provides a nice
scientific underpinning to a lot of the
hypotheses and precept positions of the
psychoanalysis.
You know?
So,
for example,
Freud hypothesized the existence of the
end.
Now there is no way I had in your brain,
but it doesn't really matter because the
ID,
the ID of the,
it is a functional category.
It's like a tool.
But there are lots of Ed like structures
in your brain,
you know,
and one of them in particular is the
hypothalamus and not thing like human
beings like to think that they're really
impressive.
Cortical cap is the thing that's,
you know,
in charge of things.
But your hypothalamus,
which is this little tiny thing that
sits at the top of your spinal cord man,
that's what's running you.
And let you know as long as you're not
hungry or not angry or not chasing after
sexual excitement and not gambling and
not addicted.
So as long as you're completely well fed
and warm and comfortable,
then you can think and you're more or
less in control.
But as soon as any of those things go
astray,
it's subcortical all the way.
You know.
And you can see this,
for example,
in conditions like Anorexia,
you know,
because Anorexia,
you can think of Anorexia as a war
between the cortex and the hypothalamus.
And I'll tell you,
man,
the only time the cortex wins is when
the anorexic dies.
Because other than that,
it's the hypothalamus that wins all the
time,
which is why anorexics cannot stop
themselves from Benji.
You know?
So they'll,
they'll cut their body weight down to
say 75% of what it should be.
And that's hard.
Like you really,
it's not easy to starve yourself like
that,
but they'll still binge like mad,
you know,
and need a whole gallon of ice cream and
two bags of bread and they can't stop
themselves.
And that's because your hypothalamus,
we would rather you didn't starve to
death.
And if you're not paying attention,
if you're not on top of the game or
maybe if you've been hurt recently and
so your resources or your,
your,
what would you say you're,
the negative emotion has been
interfering with your cognitive
capacity.
The hypothalamus will come up and grab
you and say,
man,
you're hungry.
And it's off to the fridge with you.
You know,
so two in the morning you're going to be
eating everything in there in a kind of
a daze and you'll snap out of that and
think,
wow,
what the hell was that?
It was like,
well that's the end folks.
And it's no trivial thing and it's a
good thing too because if it didn't tell
you what to do all the time,
like think about how foolish you are.
If you had to breathe voluntarily,
how,
how many days do you think you'd go
through?
It's like you wake up one day and an
hour later you'd forget to breathe and
then you'd be dead.
So like your,
your,
your brain doesn't let you do anything
important.
It takes care of all that in the
background,
you know,
cause you're just not that smart.
I mean,
you don't know how to digest things.
For example,
you actually don't know how you walk
even though you can do it.
So there are fundamental subsystem,
some of them that aren't even conscious
weirdly enough,
even though they're neurological,
they're doing all the heavy lifting and
like your cortex is along there.
It's along for the ride and some
sanction and sort of things.
It's in control.
But yeah,
no,
not really.
Okay.
So we're going to talk a fair bit about
fundamental brain structures and the
function of those structures.
Cause I liked functional neuroanatomy.
I like,
I don't want to know just what the brain
is made out of,
but I want to know what all the parts
are doing.
And so there's difficult papers in their
swans and that's a hard paper.
And the grit paper by gray,
those are papers that were written by I
think genius level neuropsychologists
and you know,
they put their whole life's work into a
paper and so you know you're going to
pick it up,
you're going to think,
wow,
this is hard.
It's like,
yeah,
some genius spent 30 years writing it.
It's going to be hard.
But there are so informative.
They're worth the struggle if,
if that's the sort of thing you want to
struggle with.
So that's the biological end.
And then there's the psychometric ended
site,
psychometrics,
very unpopular field of psychology,
even among psychologists.
And the reason for that is that
psychometric nutritions,
I guess have actually discovered things
and people hate what they've discovered
and no wonder.
So for example,
it was people who do psychometrics,
engineers actually who had,
who entered psychology,
who discovered intelligence,
technical psychometric intelligence Iq.
And people will tell you there's lots of
kinds of intelligence like,
no,
there aren't.
That's wrong.
And it's wrong in this way.
The statistics that psychologists use
were invented by the people who
discovered Iq.
And that means every single thing that a
psychologist has ever claimed that's
been verified in some way using some
statistical process has been verified,
verified,
the same way that Iq was verified.
And so you don't get to say,
well the Iq stuff's invalid without
saying all of psychology and a lot of
other fields is invalid too because it's
the same methods of proof.
And it's even worse than that because
like the relationship between Iq and
life,
success is way stronger than the
relationship between almost any other
psychological phenomena.
And almost anything else.
So for example,
for you guys even know,
you know you're,
you're all far above average in
intelligence because otherwise you
wouldn't be here like at least 85th
percentile.
And that's something to think about
because a lot of that is determined by
biological factors and also a huge chunk
of the reason that you're here is
because you know,
you one part of the genetic lottery,
so like hurray for you and no one's
screwed it up too badly as you were
growing up,
you know,
but even among you guys,
that correlation between your
intelligence and your and your grade
point average is quite high even though
it's a truncated sample,
right?
Cause you're all pretty bright and even
though there's a lot of error in the
grade measurement system because it
doesn't only index intelligence,
it's still very powerful.
And so the one,
the peep,
if you,
if you controlled for conscientious and
other elements of personality,
which you can do statistically in 20
years,
the peep,
the 10% of the people in this room who
have the highest Iq is we'll have the
highest income virtually.
Certainly,
you know,
unless some terrible thing happens to
them,
you can overcome it to some degree if
you're really hardworking cause then
that's conscientiousness,
you know,
and that,
but that's also a trait which seems to
have quite a heavy biological loading.
So well,
so that's the sort of thing that people
hate about psychometricians because they
come up with these facts and there are
facts that are really dismal.
And I can give you an example.
So,
so you guys all have an Iq of over 150
roughly speaking a hundred makes you
about as smart as the typical high
school rapping,
you know,
115 that's kind of the low end for,
for managing the rigors of a,
a fairly high end university.
You know,
one 15 you're still going to have a lot
of trouble.
Are you going to have to work like mad?
So,
but okay so 150 now that's one standard
deviation above the mean.
One standard deviation below the mean is
an Iq of 85.
Now there's just as many people out
there in the world who have an Iq of 85
as there are people who are able to go
to college.
Okay.
So then you think,
what can you do if you have an Iq of 85
and well,
one answer.
So the u s army has been doing
psychometric testing for a hundred and
some years,
um,
for a whole bunch of reasons.
But they've done a lot of the basic
science,
you know,
and uh,
one thing about the u s army is they
like to have recruits and you can
understand why,
because do you really want to go off
somewhere and get shot?
And the answer to that is generally no.
So it's not like there were people
lining up to get into the army.
Even in peace time.
It's hard to get people.
And also the Americans have used the u s
army as a,
you know,
imagine you have a,
an underclass of people who aren't doing
very well,
which is the case in every society.
And you want to boost.
Some of them up,
you know,
into something resembling the middle
class.
You can do that fairly effectively by
inducting new young men in particular
into the army because they get some
training,
you know,
when they get some discipline and maybe
they can kinda clamber up into the
middle class.
And so there's a lot of policy reasons.
A why the American army or enforces want
people and be,
you know,
just to be in the army,
but also for social reasons,
positive social reasons.
So they're not likely not to let you in
the,
the consequence of a hundred years of Iq
testing was the PR was the establishment
of a law in the United States.
You cannot induct anyone into the army,
cannot accept them into the army.
If they have an Iq of less than 82
that's 10% of the population.
So you think about that,
that means one person in 10 cannot do
anything that is a positive value in a
organization.
It's rather complex,
but not more complex than other
organizations.
That's desperate for people,
not thing they an offer has positive
value.
It's worse to have them in the army than
not to have them there at all.
Really.
Now you know that that's a terrible way
of putting it.
But it's an,
it's a horrible,
it's a horrible statistic because it
also means,
you know,
if you think about the army as roughly
equivalent to the world in some sense in
terms of its complexity,
it means that there's 10% of the
population who just cannot really exist
well in a complex cognitive society.
So,
and you might say,
well,
you know,
something should be done about that.
It's like good luck.
People had been trying to do something
about that for a very long time.
There's been billions,
if not trillions of dollars poured into
attempts to do cognitive remediation in
the United States.
Well,
not to mention that we actually have an
education system and the cool is
actually to make people smarter.
So we're going to talk a lot about
psychometrics.
And the thing about the psychometricians
is they're basically brute force status
Titian's in some ways they're
atheoretical,
you know,
and they use computer power roughly
speaking and advanced statistical
techniques to look at large data sets
and extract out patterns.
And you know,
I was,
I hated the big five when I first came
on it.
I thought,
Oh God,
this is boring.
It's like there's no theory behind it.
It's not prescriptive.
It's not interested in any literary
manner.
Like it doesn't have a good story.
Um,
it came out of,
it's so dry,
but you know,
it works and,
and that's,
that's how it is.
So we're going to spend a lot of time on
psychometrics and you know,
my lab two is done if they're a bit of
work over the last 10 years elaborating
out the big five model.
So one of the things we'll talk about is
the big 10 model and what it does
roughly speaking,
is break each of the five into two,
we call them aspects.
And they're pretty interesting.
Like they predict political belief,
for example,
quite nicely.
So conservatives tend to be more
orderly,
which is part of conscientiousness and
less creative,
less open.
And Liberals tend to be more open and
less conscientious,
which a cynic would say.
That's why they're so into income
redistribution because they actually
don't work.
So you know,
the conservatives work like mad and the
liberals say,
hey,
how about some of that money,
you know,
the system's unfair and the conservative
say,
well no we worked hard and we're not
giving you any.
Well you know,
they both have flaws in their theories,
but liberals by the way,
make very good entrepreneurs.
Like,
no,
let me rephrase that.
Most entrepreneurs are liberal in their
political outlook and that's because
they're high in openness.
So the way it really seems to work is
that liberal minded people start
businesses and conservatives run them.
So they're necessary for one another.
Yeah,
well cause the liberals being open,
they're off to the next idea,
you know?
And they don't want to attend to the
damn details.
They get bored by that.
They're not particularly orderly,
you know?
But once you've established a process
and it works,
you need someone to watch to make sure
the process keeps working well.
That's not very interesting if you're a
creative person.
So,
okay,
so
that's basically that.
That's the course.
So now at the time,
so I think what I'll do now is I'm going
to tell you a story and you're going to
think it has absolutely nothing to do
with what we've been talking about,
but that's okay.
That's okay.
So I picked this weird
picture.
Um,
it's the,
it's a picture of Jonah Biblical
character.
So 2,500 year old story.
So that's a pretty old story.
And generally if a story is 2,500 years
old,
it's a lot older than that.
You know,
it's just happened to be written down
2,500 years ago.
But you know,
that long ago it wasn't like there were
novels and books and that you could find
50 different stories,
you know,
at your fingertips.
There were a few stories and everyone
knew them and God only knows how long
they'd been around.
But it was a very,
very,
very long time.
So this was written down 2,500 years
ago,
but we don't really have any idea how
old it is.
And in some sense it's almost infinitely
old,
at least on any human scale.
Now you see this picture and what you
see is this thing that,
what would you call it?
Well it's a mid evil idea of a whale is
what it is.
You know,
when you might think,
well that isn't really what a way it
looks like.
And that's kind of right.
But a medieval Wale wasn't the whale
that we have.
Like whale in medieval times meant
large,
terrifying underwater thing,
you know?
And so maybe that was maybe a giant
squid was the whale and the whale was a
whale in the shark was a whale.
You know,
the category is not the same.
So that kind of accounts for the,
that in pure ignorance is what accounts
for the kind of strange mythologized
representation.
But it's still a representation of
something.
It's just a little generalized.
Now what he's doing is vomiting Jonah up
onto dry land.
So,
and you think that's,
that's pretty damn weird.
How many of you have Seen Pinocchio?
That's a lot.
Hey,
how many of you haven't really,
you haven't Seen Pinocchio?
What kind of parents did you have
anyways?
Okay,
well you remember in Pinocchio Pinocchio
was father is stuck in a way,
La and then Pinocchio has to go down
there and,
and,
and rescue him.
And one of the things you didn't notice
when you were watching Pinocchio is just
how daft that is.
There you are sitting there,
you're watching a puppet go down into
the ocean to rescue his father from a
whale.
And you think,
boy,
that makes sense.
It's like,
well,
so that's interesting.
Right?
That's interesting.
Why does that make sense?
Cause it doesn't make any sense but,
but,
but it's,
see that's a,
that's a good example of the grip of an
architectural idea.
Cause in archetipal ideas,
a very deep and old idea that makes
sense to you.
Even though if someone points out to you
that you believe it,
which you more or less do while you're
watching the movie,
you think,
Oh yeah,
it's really weird that I believe that.
Just like,
you know,
that isn't a puppet going down into the
ocean to rescue his father from a whale
either.
Just so you know it,
it's a drawing of a puppet going down
into the ocean to rescue as far from a
whale.
So it's like divorced from reality,
my life in all sorts of ways.
But what's so interesting is you go into
the theater and watch something like
that there.
If someone taps you on the shoulder and
say,
Hey,
do you know what you're doing?
You say,
uh,
why don't you shut up and let me watch
the movie?
Right?
You don't notice.
Oh yes.
I'm very peculiar and very peculiar
thing sitting here watching this and not
noticing how strange I am,
you know?
And so,
well,
that's partly why I'm going to tell you
this story because,
because it's true,
even though it isn't,
you know?
And,
and that's,
that's a funny thing.
I had a very,
very strange professor at the University
of Alberta.
He died a few years ago.
He got in a bus,
I think it was in Winnipeg,
and he never got off the bus and no one
ever saw him again.
So he had,
he'd been a prison psychologist,
he worked in the maximum security prison
and University of Alberta.
So who maybe he met one of his old
clients,
you know,
it's possible,
but it's very strange,
very strange ending.
Anyways,
one time,
um,
we are talking about fiction,
you know,
and he said,
uh,
he said fiction is a lie that can tell
you the truth.
And that's a very interesting way of
thinking about it.
You know,
because you read fiction and you know
it's true,
but it's not obviously because it's not
really about a thing that actually
happened,
but it's more than that some ways
because if it's good fiction,
it's about a whole bunch of things that
happen sort of like that.
Right?
It's a distillation,
it's like someone tells you a long story
and then you know,
you,
you talked to your partner and they
asked you what was that all about?
And then you tell them in two sentences
what it was about.
You boil it down to the just right.
Well,
a really good story is the gist of
something.
And some of the really old stories,
the really weird ones like Jonah and the
whale for example,
which as I said is,
is told to some degree in the story of
Pinocchio there the gist of a lot of
things and people have been boiling
those damn stories down for,
for a very,
very,
very long period of time.
Thousands of people over thousands of
years.
And they come up with these weird
stories that people remember
and then people think,
well,
they're real.
It's like,
yeah,
they are,
but they're not real.
The way a scientific story is real to
different kinds of real.
So here's,
here's the story of Jonah.
So it's an old Jewish story.
There's probably a very intimate in in
the Qur'an,
but I don't know that variant.
So,
and maybe there isn't.
Anyways,
Jonah lives in 500 BC and uh,
God has a chat with them one day and he
says,
look,
Jonah there,
there's this city,
Nineveh,
and the people there,
you know,
they're really not on the straight and
narrow and things are going to go to
hell in a handbasket very rapidly if
someone doesn't do something about that.
So I think that you should go to Nineveh
and you should tell the king and all the
people that are there that you know,
really there,
they're just not doing the right thing.
And Joan and being a perfectly
intelligent person says,
you want me to go to a city and you want
to go meet?
We didn't tell the king like this
authoritarian die who has absolute power
of everything,
that there's something wrong with what
he's doing,
that all of the citizens are corrupt.
That's what you want me to do.
And,
and Jonah says,
there's no way I'm doing that because as
I said,
he's a smart guy.
So he runs off and he goes to this town
and as he's running off,
he,
he rents a boat more or less.
And it's a big boat and there's
fishermen on it and they're going to
like row him somewhere.
God can't find it,
which is not going to be an easy thing.
And so god of course,
can't be fooled by such relatively poor
strategic choices because he's
omniscient and all that.
And so he's out on the water,
Jonah.
And there's the fishermen there.
And then,
so God calls up this big storm and the
fishermen are shorting out about this
and because they're going to swamp the
boat and then they're all going to die
and they're not that happy about that.
So what they decided to do is throw
everything overboard so that the boat is
light.
But that doesn't help much because the
storm gets worse.
And so then all of them start praying.
They all have different gods.
So you know,
it's like a little garden competition.
One fishermen talks to one God and other
fishermen talks to another God and
nothing's happening.
So Jonah happens to be asleep in the
hold of the ship.
Now he's already told them that he's
been running from his God.
And so they think,
ha,
we better go wake up Jonah because maybe
he's the guy that's causing all the
trouble.
So they'd go down there and they wake
him up and they ask him about his,
his God.
And he says,
well my God made the heavens and the
earth and their gods,
they were doing anything that
magnificent.
So they're pretty freaked out about
this.
And so they tell Joan,
it's like,
what the hell are you running away from
this guy for?
It's not a good idea.
And Jonah says,
yeah,
I'm sure it's my fault that this storm
has come up.
So why you just throw me over?
And they say,
well,
we can't really do that because you
know,
you shouldn't run away like that,
but you're not a murderer or anything.
We can't just toss you over.
And so they decided to try to row to
shore,
but God's not having any of that.
So he raises up a big storm and it's
getting worse and worse.
And finally the fishermen say,
Oh,
you know,
over you go.
And June is into that because he knows
he's a bad guy.
And so a all swallows them.
Now you think that's probably not
exactly right because first if a whale
swallowed you,
then you'd be dead.
And it was probably a shark anyways.
It's not like you're going to be private
down there.
It's not a big cavern.
Like,
you know the Pinocchio Whale,
it's,
it's solid and there's no oxygen.
And so your dad,
but that isn't what happens.
Joan is in the whale and he's Kinda
freaked out by this cause now he's in a
whale and there's a storm in God's angry
at him.
So the first thing he does is pray and
tell God what an idiot.
He isn't it,
you know,
he'd like to be forgiven.
I mean,
so the whale zips up to shore and vomits
him onto the beach,
which is the very,
very undignified mode of arriving
anywhere.
So,
so that's,
that's the Jonah Story.
And then of course,
Jonah picks himself up and he thinks he,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
that wasn't so good.
It was a little rough.
I think maybe I'm going off to Nineveh
to tell the ninevites or whoever they
were that they're just not living
properly because that's a lot better
than making God angry,
you know?
Cause what with the storms in that
fishermen and the whales and all that.
So then he goes off to Nineveh and he
tells them what's going on and it seems
to more or less work.
So,
so that's a very interesting story.
And you think,
well how did people believe that me?
And one question might be,
well,
do you believe that story?
And then you think,
well no,
but then you think,
well maybe that's more complex question
than you might think because it turns
out that I believe the Pinocchio Story
and you say,
well no,
I didn't really believe it.
And then I would say,
well it kind of depends on what you mean
by bleed,
doesn't it?
Because you watched it and while you
were watching it,
man,
you are into it.
You understood it.
You didn't want it to be disrupted.
You followed it.
So it's like,
did you believe it?
No.
You were like a four year old skeptics
sitting there thinking,
well,
you know,
puppet whale.
No,
it doesn't bad.
No you're not.
You're acting out your belief in it by
being engaged in it.
And if someone taps you on the shoulder
and wakes you up 30 years later,
20 years later,
you say,
oh no,
I don't believe that.
It's like,
you know,
it's kind of remarkable what you believe
in.
How many of you are star wars?
Like a fist unidos?
No,
you won't admit it,
will you?
Yeah,
but there's lots of you in here.
I know.
You know.
And so that's all mythologies and told
him mythology.
You know that of course,
the person who,
uh,
what was his name?
The guy who came up with the star wars
idea?
Lucas Lucas was a student of Joseph
Campbell.
Joseph Campbell was a psychologist slash
mythologist and the star wars stories
are updated mythology,
just like Harry Potter and all the other
things that capture people's
imagination.
So you bloody well do believe this.
And there's a reason for it to now,
what time is it?
Oh,
stop there.
I'll tell you the reason the next time
we meet.